[Music]
a fire broke out at europe's largest
nuclear power plant in ukraine amid
shelling as russia's invasion entered
its ninth day
russian troops moved into the zappo
regia facility as the blaze at a
training building next to the reactors
raised concerns over moscow's evolving
tactics and a potential nuclear disaster
ukraine has 15 nuclear reactors
according to the international atomic
energy agency the country's emergency
service said the blaze was extinguished
friday morning none of the six reactors
were affected and there was no radiation
leak
russia's assault on the facility
prompted calls between western leaders
and the ukrainian president vladimir
zelinsky
in recent days residents of the city set
up barriers and occupied roads to stop
russian troops from advancing closer to
the nuclear plant
as the second round of talks between
russia and ukraine ended on thursday
without a ceasefire deal but an
agreement on humanitarian corridors
zielenski called for a direct meeting
with russian president vladimir putin
during a televised address putin said
everything is under control
but moscow has faced strong resistance
from ukrainian forces and citizens and
has carried out many attacks on civilian
areas western officials say russia could
resort to siege tactics to trap the
ukrainian population inside urban areas
cutting them off from food and supplies
[Music]